I went to uh I mean by the time this is
out it's pretty darn I I went to uh
uh go to sex store
um because Ludwig wanted me to get him
the idea of the video is that he gets me
a box of 500 with the stuff from America
that got America themed yeah and he
wants a Japanese themed box or right 500
of the Japanese stuff I've done some
cool stuff you know uh but you know I
had to go to the sex store I was like I
gotta give that because I'm thinking
content I want to give him content what
is better than content than half the
stuff in those goddamn stores yeah but
the problem is how do I get stuff that
he can show on a live stream yeah and I
found stuff well it was just weird
enough
no that's that's like vanilla from all
the stuff I found there was this thing
like vanilla I'm thinking stream needs
again I found the
never seen these before I I know they've
only existed before but this is a new
thing to me it was it was branded in
this face hole TM and it was just Anime
characters but there wasn't a flashlight
it was just an anime character and you
you do the thing to its face
so it's like it's like a it's like
shaped like a mouth or something it's
shaped like a body and then you it like
it like curves like this like a natural
you know body you know you had to head
here yeah oh yeah yeah so it's like and
on the side there's like a 3D like
diagram cross-section of what it looks
like on the inside yeah and I guess you
just have to put your mouth in it and
then go all the way down the thing it
was [ __ ] wait so where is like is
like the neck hole or like the mouth
mouth curves
so like yo your pp's doing some
contortion
um right and they had like the they had
the it was like a package deal so you
could get this and then down below for
like 500 yeah and five bucks yeah you
can get some some of that lube for this
anime it wasn't any lube it was like an
injection Lube because obviously have to
get it deep in there right so it's like
a little [ __ ] needle yeah I was like
this is just too much this is too much
and some of the clothes they were
selling I was like my goodness I bought
like a fake camel toe something I don't
know who needs this oh fake Hamilton
what's the obsession with camel toe here
what's up with that what is the
obsession with that I guess some people
just really like it yeah I don't know
and then I got the sprays obviously of
course yeah armpit sprays men some of
those things any sprays yeah well some
of them like I had to make sure the box
art was safe for work so a lot of them
were just sweaty girls and it's just
like whoo see I've I've been through
like here in store I've been through
this yeah yeah for years now like yeah
this is like going on shopping trips or
Sydney for like her next her newest
video and it's just like yeah this is
this is just normal now I every Walk of
Life was in that store buying stuff of
course the oldest man who definitely
shouldn't have been is definitely way
too old advice on this stuff but yeah
props to you yeah and you know a bunch
of couples were in there and a bunch of
younger people than me oh God I feel old
saying there um young people
I'm not buying all like the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] putting it in my cart like yeah I'm
not weird and then I'm like this is
really weird this is really fun but
that's the thing right it's like I feel
the the best part about those kinds of
stores is like when you have a friend
come to Japan and you're just like yo
show me some like weird Japan
I got you there was some other stuff
yeah and the one in Harbor right next to
the station yeah the Green Building yeah
dude there was this weird I'd never seen
this before it was a body pillow that
had a blow up portion to it and the and
they were like blow up legs yeah like
this yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
attached to the bodycon I know what I
said he's got that why
because some dudes just want to grab the
[ __ ] legs yeah yeah
floaty combined with a pillow yeah it's
it's like as how as close you can get to
a sex doll as possible without actually
buying a three thousand dollar sex doll
you know there are different tiers you
know it'd be really funny if you like
throw throw one of those into a pool and
you just see like a bunch of little eggs
because you know the body the pillow
part's gonna stick it's just a bunch of
legs oh that's so nice yeah there's so
much here oh I should not exist yeah at
all there was a Tanga that was bigger
but of course it was labeled the US
Tenga oh yeah yeah it was black
give me the exercise thing I I felt like
such a Chad rocking up to the stores
like one US Tenga for me please
nice awesome questionable [ __ ] um on my
tank of videos oh yeah we did holy [ __ ]
the the weight one was my favorite one I
[ __ ] love that but also that would be
like that would be that would be an easy
way to destroy your dick as well it's
kind of like eventually wait okay so
this is a thing right so when I did the
Tenga video with God no uh they they
brought us like a bunch I was like show
me all the weird [ __ ] I want to show all
the weird [ __ ] off and they were like we
got you and they brought out this one
which was in this wooden like chest yeah
basically probably about that big right
pick this thing up heavy as a
[ __ ] and I'm like this is a this
is a this is a tinga right a little
[ __ ] orb open it up it's this metal I
I how heavy was it was like five ten
pounds it was 10 kilograms 10 kilograms
is this 10 kilogram metal cover for your
Tango and the idea of it is that why
would you J.O when you can work out at
jail yeah it's literally you can lift
and it's like the packaging is just this
like [ __ ] ripped dude just like
holding this thing I saw that there's a
Tango workout package yeah yeah yeah it
costs 500 oh yeah I saw this yeah yeah I
was like what the [ __ ] it was you
working yeah I mean the the yeah the
thing literally [ __ ] like I'm walking
out
quagmires
yeah the thing looked like an Iron
Maiden for your dick you know it was a
[ __ ] it was a [ __ ] saw trap in a
box you know like I can imagine like
this you're like sore 20 and you just
have 30 minutes yeah
to pump 200 times without destroying
your dick because the thing is it's like
next episode of euphoria yeah because
the thing is if you let it go for a
second it would literally just crush
your [ __ ] dick because this thing's
so heavy yeah and I'm like wait and the
guy was like unsurprisingly they're not
in they're not for sale anymore and I'm
like yeah no [ __ ] I I saw a full-on it
looked like a pool pump that had been
like retooled into a sex toy what oh
straight up yeah yeah like a giant dick
pump right like a like a very powerful
dick pump and I thought who the [ __ ]
Austin Powers
it's just like combining four Dyson
brand new like v10s into one suck on max
this is like ridiculous I'm like what
what is happening like what is what do
you need do you need like like the
[ __ ] uh the Teletubbies Hoover to
jack you off like what is going on I
remember I remember watching that
awesome the first Austin Powers movie
with the with the dick pump like a bit
and I'm just like there was a pump this
was a straight up like a like a full-on
jet engine suction but but I remember
thinking when I was watching that movie
I'm like this is hilarious this thing
can't exist in real life yeah and then a
couple of years later I found out no
these things exist there's an audience
wait what's the point of Dick pumps
again I forgot just to momentarily make
you dig a little bigger right is it
really isn't it I think that's what it
is you're asking me as if I've used yeah
we've known can you look up the purpose
can you can you look I know you're on
the company looking up on the uh work
yeah yeah that's the that's the middle
that's the thing he came in as well
that's it yeah I mean some of the things
the creativity some of those Tangers
that we were shown on the uh on the
Tenga video was like way too much like
says some of them were they had like if
a team
has a [ __ ] motor the auto rotates
your tengo for you you know I'm sorry
when you're having sex you're not
rotating exactly you know what I mean
like you're you're not like oh hold up
seconds like it goes on top of you just
like just just trust me I got a new sex
position it's called the helicopter
get your fellow get your fellow uh
Speedwagon enjoy it'll hold on to the
ceiling fan and then get a ladder
like what are you like I don't
understand like the obsession of like
it's like it's like God did not decide
that we could make these motions exactly
this is these are not even make them
with your hands
like these are nice
we are not allowed to do these so when I
hear the technology is doing this yeah
no no because what if you get what if
you get to the point this has got to
have happened there's a guy out there in
Japan I just cannot not if my dick is
not rotating yeah three three rotations
at least ten rotations a minute like
like what happens when that happens
yeah that's definitely definitely
there's a dude out there there's at
least one I would like to argue many
tens and hundreds of dudes because they
have too much good sex toys yeah yeah I
think that's a problem that's they're
too good yeah they're too good yeah when
when we when we refer to like yo how
many RPM do you go up to when you jack
off
yeah
you're like man I didn't enjoy the Tango
rotate you're like bro no wrong RPM
RPM with uh repulsory 50 rpm weak I I go
100 at least yeah I saw that and like
you know how you see like some of those
ads sometimes where you just like try
out this game you won't you'll last 10
seconds or less you know that's actually
like real [ __ ] advertising for some
of these [ __ ] sex toys man I swear to
God so Kai what's the purpose of a dig
pop
clothes
encourage blood flow
it's like a natural Viagra no kind of it
lasts as long yeah well obviously it
doesn't last as long but it's like yeah
it's it's it's it's the equivalent to
that yeah but no that's definitely
happened I mean I think there's even
like an issue right now where you know
some there are people who are addicted
to porn and everything like that and you
know they're so they're like less
sensitive now to actual real sex
it's been hard to do anything that is
true recent hentai's been kind of whack
not gonna lie it's been awful yeah we'll
save them
is it is it weird that and I've always
found this weird and I know I've pointed
out many times because I feel Japan is
the only one that is so open to that
kind of [ __ ] but at the same time he's
just like no we don't want to talk about
it right because it's like because
because I find it weird that you can go
to any Don Quijote and there's just like
an open section for Daniel like it's not
even behind a curtain I feel like it's
it's uh what's the word where you're
kind of constricted uh like Society here
is very um what's the word when you're
held back a little bit um oppressed yeah
a little bit right like the the
people have to really hold back their
personalities a lot in Japan yeah and I
feel like that results in them just
getting [ __ ] wild they have to hold
back yeah when they when they get to
like let loose and do their thing it
feels like you know if you're gonna make
me work like 50 goddamn hours a week and
make me work on like weekends the least
I can do is just do whatever the [ __ ] I
want and if I want to have a good Jack
offset if I if I wanna they're gonna
hold they're gonna hold back a different
thing is if I want to do some weird ass
[ __ ] that I I have participated in the
society and done what you've asked to me
and I'm doing it yeah I mean and so I
feel like that's that kind of just that
letting loose is where it comes from a
little bit oh no definitely well I think
it's also the big reason why like a lot
of you know that side of the industries
for example like you know like the Doge
inside of things that's why we get some
of like the weirdest like what the [ __ ]
type of ideas because it's like you're
yeah because in a daily life you're not
releasing it as often so it builds up
and builds up yeah or even discussing it
into and turns into something that's
just like how the [ __ ] do you think
about that yeah right so yeah at least
see the people not talking about it at
all not wanting to engage with it or
going just insane and being not insane
but like going wild with them yeah
because like you know go on people
people still have thoughts you know
people yeah
yeah if there's no if you can't Bonk
that away then uh what are you supposed
to do